aah situation situation our order is
inacceptable
s de Presidente at acabo de mañana de
los immigrant aces inacceptable a voyeur
can be arrested one day one I will make
sure that number one we end the ice
policies and the customs and border
policies are violating the human rights
when people come to this country who do
not leave their human rights at the
border number two I will make sure that
we reinstate daca that we reinstate
pathways to citizenship for daca
recipients and to make sure that people
that are here on temporary protective
status can stay and remain here and then
finally we need to make sure that we
address the issues that made Oscar and
valaria come in the first place by
making major investments in the northern
triangle not like this president is
doing by ripping away the resources we
need to actually solve this problem we
cannot surrender our values and then
think that we're going to get border
security we actually will lose security
and our values we must fight for both I
give